poursuivant là dessus avec un maxime roy
à la porte parole du regroupement des
comités logement et associations de
locataires du québec
alors le cas de madame nice et celle là
c'est un cas parmi tant d'autres dites
nous à ce stade ci est ce qu'on se
dirige vers un 1er juillet
catastrophique le 1er juillet très
difficile dans les comtés logement
montréal dans d'autres régions du québec
il ya des centaines voire des milliers
de locataires qui cherche encore des
logements abordables qui n'en trouvent
pas donc il doit s'adresser aux
ressources communautaires aux ressources
municipales
mais les logements abordables sont très
rares c'est ce qu'on a démontré dans
l'antre étude des lois des logements à
louer sur kijiji donc ils logements qui
sont encore disponibles sont souvent
extrêmement chers et donc ils le kata
n'arrive pas à payer ses loyers la wii
avec donc des prix et qui sont en hausse
qu'est ce qui explique en gros la scène
au cela les mêmes raisons que l'an
dernier et que l'hôte années d'avant
quoi mais la spéculation immobilière
fait mal au québec donc il est propre et
attendent augmenter rapidement les prix
des loyers en raison de l'absence de
réglementation forte à d'aucuns avaient
fait le même exercice que nous en 2015
le prix moyen d'un loyer dans le grand
montréal étaient de 860 il est
aujourd'hui 40% plus cher donc on voit
l'augmentation rapide des prix des
loyers dans le secteur de montréal
dans certains secteurs comme le secteur
de madame l'arrêt dans le sud ouest
verdun
les loyers sont autour de 1500 1600 $
pour inquiéter demi willie dans le
logement alors mais dans tout ça faut
bien rappeler l'association des
propriétaires du québec vous reproche de
comparer et distille des pommes avec des
oranges selon leurs données mais année
après année les coûts du logement au
monde plutôt autour de 2% parfois même -
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cette
affirmation
en fait le j'ai juste de comparer des
pommes avec des pommes en comparant deux
études de 50 des différences nos
relations de 40%
c'est sûr que si on se compare avec la
schl c'est un peu différent de la chl
enquête sur tous les logements
mais je répondrai à monsieur brouillette
serait toronto vancouver est ce qu'on
veut que montréal où d'autres villes du
québec devienne le projet tente où le
prochain à vancouver je les vitres aller
visiter les rues de toronto vancouver et
des personnes itinérantes de manière
importante les gens s'en vont dans des
camps de fortune parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à trouver des logements abordables
est-ce qu'on veut devenir le prochain
toronto je ne crois pas
il faut préserver le jeune preneur
pendant qu'il est encore temps parlons
de solution à vous proposer enregistre
des loyers qui permettrait donc aux
locataires aux futurs locataires de voir
qu'on mais quel prix est exigée
précédemment alors ça ça pourrait être
une solution mais elle est coûteuse
cette solution répond la ministre la
forêt et les coûteuses aux yeux doux
regard des chiffres depuis plusieurs
années la technologie a évolué depuis on
pense que ça coûterait pendant le moins
cher que ça mais faut pas regarder
seulement l'aspect financier ont
instauré un contrôle un régis des loyers
et incontrôlée loyer ça permettrait de
sauver pendant des milliards de dollars
en spéculation immobilière donc des gens
qui payent beaucoup trop cher leur
hypothèque pour leur loyer ça
reviendrait la société ultérieurement
donc faut regarder les choses de ce côté
là incontrôlée loyers comme il se fait
en ontario par exemple où elle est
propriétaire doivent justifier leurs
hausses de loyer supérieures à un taux
maximal aussi des effets bénéfiques en
gardant des logements plus abordent donc
l'idée d'inverser le fardeau c'est ça
qui ne sont pas sur les épaules des
locataires mais bien des propriétaires
qui doivent justifier la hausse et c'est
le principe de votre association vous
proposer exactement parce qu'en ce
moment les locataires craignent de
refuser aux loyers parce que ne
connaissent pas leurs droits ou ils
veulent pas envenimer les relations que
la propriété donc on veut renverser ce
fardeau là et que toute hausse
supérieure à l'inflation par exemple
soit justifié de manière jeu équitables
et tranchée par le tribunal qui est la
régie du logement
et quand les propriétaires répondants
disent en actes et les coûts de
rénovation les assurances ce sont des
coûts qui sont sous-estimés en
justifiant donc leur approche
oui mais il faut garder que l'immobilier
c'est un investissement à moyen long
terme sur le long terme puis les
chiffres le démontrent
c'est payant donc faut pouvoir les
choses de manière équitable si les
loyers en beauce une bonne partie des
hypothèques voilà totalité sur le long
terme
elle est venue propriétaires vont revoir
leur argent lorsqu'ils vont vendre leurs
investissements l'immobilier en ce
moment et en montrer rapidement donc oui
c'est payant à long terme êtes vous
d'avis que qu'effectivement l'ajout de
logements de nouveaux logements au cours
des prochaines années en 2020 en fait
pour avoir une incidence positive sur
après des loyers sur les banques est ce
qu'on construit son construit seulement
des logements ni condos les appartements
locatifs lecture ça va avoir un impact
et un impact important
les loyers vont continuer à augmenter
aussi rapidement ici par conséquent on
construit aussi des logements sociaux
comme on a le besoin plus que jamais
mais pour ça il faut que le grand du
québec investissent et avec le fédéral
des sommes conséquentes pour permettre
aux villes et aux différentes régions du
québec de construire de manière
importante des logements sociaux parce
que c'est la seule solution pour garder
les logements abordables et dans le
contexte actuel quel recours existent
pour les personnes justement qui qui
sont aux prises avec cette augmentation
ils craignent ne pas pouvoir répondre ou
plutôt payer verser les sommes qui sont
demandés mais là se sentent
catastrophique à quelques jours du 1er
juin des gens qui confèrent au oui deux
premiers on peut trouver pour toujours
trouver des logements qui doivent se
retourner vers les ressources
communautaires les ressources
municipales à montréal l'office
municipal d'habitation prévoyait
virginie environ une centaine de ménages
au 1er juillet donc dans différentes
villes il ya des ressources comme ça
mais il faut aussi contacter les comités
logement les associations de locataires
qui sont là pour aider les locataires à
défendre leurs droits par exemple
lorsque survient une grosse de loyer
abusives
très bien merci beaucoup au revoir merci